[Musica]
nel primo trimestre del 2022 in Italia
si sono dimesse volontariamente
519 mila persone e di quelli che non si
sono dimessi una buona parte ha deciso
ormai da tempo di non coinvolgersi più
di tanto nel lavoro
Ma qual è la ragione che spinge le
persone a lasciare il posto di lavoro o
accontentarsi del minimo indispensabile
a quanto pare non è nello stipendio né
le politiche di welfare perché la
ragione più diffusa sembra essere la
mancanza di opportunità di crescita la
sensazione cioè che nel lavoro in quel
lavoro non ci sia un'occasione per sé
eppure non mancano i team building non
mancano gli Assessment personalizzati
non manca la gestione automatizzata dei
reward che cosa serve ancora
Forse abbiamo dato per scontato di
sapere il significato della parola
crescere e soprattutto abbiamo
erroneamente pensato che per farlo il
modo migliore fosse puntare tutto sulla
performance individuale
crescere condivide la sua radice latina
con il verbo creare
significa Cioè creare la propria persona
ma In che cosa consiste questo processo
che cosa lo guida sostanzialmente cosa
In che cosa consiste la crescita
ultimamente va molto di moda la frase
diventa chi sei o diventa la migliore
versione di te
Peccato che queste frasi abbiano il
grande pregio di suonare benissimo e il
grande difetto di essere completamente
prive di concretezza di senso pratico
quasi certamente i fiumi ci diranno che
siamo noi in un incessante lavoro
mentale e analitico a poterci dire chi
siamo
a trovare definire con la migliore
versione di noi
di solito sono anche gli stessi che poi
vogliono venderci pacchetti di
meditazione tre per due o retritti in
destinazioni esotiche salvo poi renderci
conto che quello che troviamo in quella
ricerca isolata di chi siamo
è un mix fatto della storia che ci
raccontiamo di condizionamenti esterni
senza filtro a cui Pensavamo di essere
impermeabili
conditi da una buona dose di indecisione
della serie Oggi dico di essere così
domani penso di essere cosa
e se ci fossimo sbagliati
se il modo migliore per rispondere alla
domanda chi sono e cosa posso diventare
quella tipica cioè della crescita
fosse creare delle condizioni nuove un
contesto nuovo
Quanti di voi hanno visto questa
immagine o qualcosa di simile magari con
una frase motivazionale scritta in basso
nel loro luogo di lavoro
sono sicura che ci sia ancora qualcosa
di simile in qualche sala riunioni
Questa è la classica metafora aziendale
del andiamo insieme uniti un passo dopo
l'altro verso l'obiettivo
Ma quanto è verosimile questa metafora
quanti di noi possono davvero dire che
questo è esattamente quello che accade
nel loro posto di lavoro
Ecco io credo che ci siamo concentrati
così tanto nel Uniti verso l'obiettivo
nel non fermarsi nella soddisfazione
alla fine della salita che ci siamo
dimenticati un pezzo fondamentale
che cosa sta succedendo qui
ci sono delle persone che camminano
Ma che tipo di relazione c'è tra di loro
Nella migliore delle ipotesi stanno
parlando dei fatti loro Per distrarsi
dalla fatica Nella peggiore si stanno
lamentando
o soprattutto stanno parlando male di
chi c'è prima di chi c'è dopo e
soprattutto di chi c'è davanti
Sta di fatto che in questa salita verso
L'obiettivo non ci siamo mai chiesti
cosa ce ne facciamo del tratto di strada
dopo la partenza e prima dell'arrivo Che
cosa accade in quello spazio e in quel
tempo
a luglio del 2020 dopo un corso
formativo di cui ero guida ho sentito un
forte desiderio di continuare a crescere
ma anche una profonda solitudine data
dal lavoro improprio
Desideravo una compagnia non tanto nelle
cose da fare quotidianamente quanto
nella possibilità di sentirmi a fianco a
qualcuno mentre ciascuno faceva il suo
pezzo un po' Come era successo in quel
corso di formazione così ho chiesto a
sei libere professioniste se avevano
voglia di creare con me un coworking
virtuale L'avevo chiamato
L'idea era quella di trovarsi ogni
settimana per due ore in uno spazio
online dove ciascuno potesse portare una
fase critica del suo lavoro e le altre
potessero dire come la vedevano loro
dalla loro zona di osservazione
per due anni abbiamo ininterrottamente
lavorato
per creare uno spazio in cui ciascuna
potesse portare le proprie domande
sapendo che più che una risposta avrebbe
ottenuto un'espansione di quelle domande
e quindi uno spazio di scoperta di sé
non mi ero resa conto che quello che
stavamo facendo ogni settimana era
prenderci cura di quello spazio dopo la
partenza e prima dell'arrivo
quello in cui abbiamo capito avviene la
crescita Ecco allora l'intuizione la
crescita forse non ha a che fare con una
spinta individuale Ma con uno spazio
collettivo condiviso
esiste in natura un modo di muoversi in
gruppo che segue semplici leggi della
fisica
è quello che regola gli storni distorni
a scuola in fisica facevo abbastanza
schifo Quindi lascio da parte le formule
e tengo solo quello che ci interessa
oggi
in estrema sintesi in uno stormo
distorni i movimenti si diffondono per
propagazione Questo significa che un
esemplare in gruppo si muove imitando il
movimento di Altri sei sette storni
vicino a lui in una frazione di tempo
così impercettibile che il movimento che
si genera è incredibilmente armonico
la coesione del gruppo nel caso degli
storni rappresenta la possibilità di
condividere un grande numero di
informazioni rilevanti come la direzione
migratoria i luoghi migliori per
l'approvvigionamento del cibo
la e garantendo calore durante il volo
capacità di confondere i predatori e di
reagire attivamente agli stimoli esterni
sostanzialmente gli storni stanno
insieme perché gli conviene non per
creare coreografie nel cielo
Ma qual è la ragione che può tenere
insieme uno stormo umano che lavora a
fianco a fianco ogni giorno o che si
trova ogni settimana
una sola
l'ipotesi l'intuizione soprattutto la
speranza che là dentro in quelle
relazioni ci sia lo spazio per scoprire
se stessi per costruire la propria
persona
abbiamo bisogno degli altri per scoprire
chi siamo non perché siano loro a
dircelo Ma perché condividano con noi
uno spazio fatto di domande e di
restituzioni costruttive
abbiamo bisogno di colleghi che sappiano
ampliare il campo visivo e accettare la
prospettiva degli altri perché non
esiste un solo modo di affrontare un
lavoro
per questo abbiamo bisogno di leader che
sappiano ascoltare e fare domande ma
soprattutto abbiamo bisogno di capi che
sappiano creare ogni giorno quello
spazio nel mezzo quello dove avviene la
crescita
e ne abbiamo bisogno per una ragione
molto semplice per sentirci parte per
appartenere a uno spazio dove la
crescita È un terreno comune
chi appartiene ad un luogo del genere e
si muove con coraggio pieno di
iniziativa e senza timore davanti alla
solitudine alle domande che contano
che appartiene Non ha timore del
feedback o del giudizio di chilizza di
fianco perché sa che quello che viene
giudicato è il suo lavoro non la sua
persona
chi sa di appartenere un luogo del
genere sale su un palco per condividere
un intuizione forse una possibilità
sapendo che comunque vada quello è un
passo per la sua crescita
gli storni non si chiedono se è il caso
di unirsi agli altri o di mantenersi
informazioni
lo fanno e basta e ne vedono la
convenienza
a noi cosa manca per fare lo stesso
ci manca una cosa che è l'origine di
tutte le altre è il primo movimento che
propaga tutti gli altri
ed è la fiducia
attenzione per affidarsi non è un
sentimento ma è un processo e una
pratica piena di contenuto
fidarsi nel caso dell'uomo movimento
intenzionale è tutt'altro che Naturale
perché si muove sulla base di un'ipotesi
rischiosa e cioè che anche l'altro come
me desideri crescere e realizzarsi nel
lavoro
vale la pena rischiare
Beh immaginatevi se nello spazio di
lavoro ci fosse questo questa
possibilità di scoperta di sé e ciascuno
si potesse mettere al servizio della
scoperta dell'altro
immaginatevi se gli Assessment i team
building le riunioni avessero come
obiettivo questa crescita comune
immaginatevi l'ampiezza della
prospettiva che si verrebbe a creare E
immaginatevi che tipo di ricchezza
verrebbe generata anche fuori dal lavoro
nel tessuto sociale e in ogni situazione
in cui abbiamo a che fare con gli altri
Beh questo è quello che potrebbe
accadere
e mentre accade si muove e si realizza
esattamente quello per cui abbiamo
creato un'impresa abbiamo scelto quella
strada professionale o abbiamo deciso di
lavorare insieme
mentre ciascuno si muove con fiducia nel
movimento dell'altro scopre e vive
quella direzione per cui le persone non
scappano dal posto di lavoro ma
rimangono in quel movimento
perché sanno che la strada è sì
personale ma riconoscono che è proprio
lì proprio in quello Stormo che possono
continuare a crescere
Grazie
[Applauso]